[موسيقى]
مرحبا يا أمي نحن أقصر الآن
اتضح أن قرية بوتشا تقف معنا
الهجوم هنا توقف هنا
نحن نخسر الحرب التي أمرت بالقتل
كل من نراه حمقى بوتين
خذها ولن ننجح بأي شكل من الأشكال
[موسيقى]
لا يمكننا أن نأخذ كييف نحن مجرد قرية
كلهم أرادوا هنا بوقاحة لا
تبين أنهم يريدون الناس أفضل
الموقع على ما يرام ، لا نوع
الحروب ليست مجرد عملية خاصة ، بل هي في الحقيقة
الفعل
[موسيقى]
الجثث ملقاة على طرق المدنيين
الكذب حولها مارس الجنس على الطريق مباشرة
[موسيقى]
الجميع يفعل ذلك
احتجزناهم في قسم العراة
نظرت إلى جميع الملابس
حسنًا ، ثم يتم اتخاذ قرار التخلي
لهم أم لا لأنهم إذا تركوها
يمكنهم تسليم مواقفنا حسنا و
مقرر
[موسيقى]
حتى لو أخذنا أسرى ، فهذا ضروري
تحتوي على إطعامه بينما لدينا
الوحيد الكثير
[موسيقى]
إنها حرب أمي ، إنها فقط أغبى شيء.
قرار دولتنا ، على ما أعتقد
عندما كان يمارس الجنس بالفعل
انتهى هذا كل شيء
بوتين يقول كل شيء يسير حسب خطة كل شيء
في الوقت المحدد